[Music]
hey folks welcome back to the never
ending apocalypse of sweetness and light
also to the second half of the dark
horse podcast live stream q and a number
102.
you hit that suit effect during the
break didn't you no i did not i'm uh i'm
i'm operating on endogenous drugs only
at the moment yeah now i actually know
that to be true
all right uh we're gonna we're gonna
stick to an hour today which means we
got a lot of great questions today we're
not gonna get to a lot of them i
apologize in advance but um you are
feeling it you were feeling a little bit
of the the head cold you got oh my god
yeah it's really not bad but i've also
lost my ability to tolerate these things
with the pandemic which has insulated us
from right semi-periodic illnesses that
we would otherwise have gotten used to
yeah exactly
but my own tongue um
first question from the discord server
this week first question is from the
discord server this week
i have owned several so they pose
questions and then the people on the
discord server to which you get access
if you join either of our patreons vote
on what is their favorite for the week
i have owned several pets dogs and cats
that can tell the difference between men
and women without any training most
humans i know can't tell the difference
between a male versus female cat or dog
without deep inspection
why do you think human sexes are so
identifiably different compared to the
difference in many other mammals which
is often very subtle
so
fun question interesting question
there are a number of answers to it one
of which is that mammals are
particularly adept
of all the senses at smell
the exception to that rule in mammals
being specifically primates
for whom vision has become prominent you
can you can see evidence of this
in the brains but also just even in the
positioning of our eyes which have moved
from the sides of our heads more frontal
so that we have binocular vision and
from the reduction the size of our
snouts
such that we have you know we just don't
have nearly as much going on in in smell
land and a lot more going on in vision
land whereas our dogs and our cats you
look at them they're real snouty they've
got long noses
and lots of ability to distinguish
presumably male from female by that
mechanism and so they are
distinguishing one another by that
mechanism as well they you know you say
that we can't tell the difference
between male and female cats and dogs uh
without deep inspection as you say well
hey i would say um
in some you know in some
i think everyone will have run into
males at least of domestic cats and
domestic dogs were like there's no
question that's a male because they just
have more robust um skulls uh skull
structure for instance um but it's also
true that they are never going to be
confused even the ones who are so called
fixed uh which is you know most of the
animals that you run into
uh are going to be able to smell the
difference between male and female so i
have a bunch of there's so much here
right like we could go on for an hour a
long time one thing i would say is i'm
not 100 convinced by
the premise of the question i think we
are actually much more um
definably different between the sexes
but i think because it's our species we
would think so no matter what absolutely
um on the other hand i think we belong
but i mean i think the way that the the
premise works then is
um
our pets seem to be able to tell
differences between human male and
female why can't we so easily tell the
difference between
domestic cat and dog male and female so
that's that's where the symmetry seems
to be presented in the question yeah i'm
not even sure i'd buy that either
because basically our and i will get
back to this but our pets are very good
i think at identifying us individually
and so it's not even clear to me
well but um i guess i've known i've
known dogs
who
and i think this is probably where this
is coming from and people say this about
cats too i haven't actually known any
cats for which this is true and i've met
a lot more cats than dogs well um but
i've definitely known dogs who had a
predilection for one sex or the other
right including strangers like you could
predict okay someone's coming over
the dog has never met that person before
and you can predict the sort of the
valence of the initial reaction based on
the sex of the person right but i'm not
convinced that that's that they are
distinguishing the sex and then it's
like oh that's in the category i prefer
something like that it could be that
there's something about the way males
interact females interact so it could be
a third correlate
but nonetheless i would say i believe
human beings belong solidly in the
category of creatures that these things
are easily distinguished so for example
siamangs males and females are different
colors i think i have that right
um
um
uh in rough skin newts males and females
are very different size and have a
different
body shape
uh so anyway there are lots of creatures
for which there is no ambiguity and i
believe gosh i find breakfast and newt's
actually tough often
um
at least at least during non-mating
season
yeah males have the big flat tail
uh
females are rounder you can also i mean
i know the descriptions i just don't
find it particularly easy all right well
i take back that one elephant seals
there's a long list of creatures that
are easy to distinguish there are others
in which you can learn it even if it's
not intuitive
you know
bald eagles
females are
a bit larger i believe in general the
raptors have sexual size dimorphism in
which the females are larger than the
males yes they compete in three
dimensions but anyway the point is i
think we're just in in one of the in
that category we're easily distinguished
um
because we're sexually dimorphic in ways
that are are recognizable
um i also whereas both um you know cats
who who have evolved domestic cats have
evolved from a solitary creature and
even domestic dogs which have evolved
from a non-solitary creature but a pack
hunting creature all adults regardless
of sex have to be involved in the hunt
and in securing food for themselves in
the case of you know the wolves from
which our dogs evolved for the group and
so they you would expect uh a more close
alignment sort of less sexual size and
sexual um form dimorphism uh in those
species for whom adults regardless of
sucks are required to do a particular
job
yep
i would also say cats are interesting
because
i i mean i have now have
decades of experience with cats and i
can't reliably tell the difference based
on morphology but
i do believe i can tell the difference
based on behavior and it's not 100
reliable because obviously a cat that is
shy it's very hard to see enough
behavior that you know and both male and
female cats can be shy
but um there is there is to me a
distinction between the way male cats
and female cats approach the world and
um i i'd be interesting to know i'd like
to i'd like to actually test my sense
that i can diagnose them because i'm
sure no i think that's fascinating i
also not not apropos the question but i
think um
i think cook coloring cats is predictive
of some personality traits
well uh yeah there may be that and
obviously
uh certain coats are only properties of
females just one as far as i know just
the tortoise shell
um
i am not actually sure
that it is just the tortoise shell it's
these patchy coats um that result from
inactivation of a different x yeah but i
mean so calicos i believe they're male
calicos whereas tortoise shells is a
very particular one that emerges from
the from the mechanism you just
described well anyway we should look
into it but obviously then it would be
somewhat predictive of uh behavior yeah
but i mean that's not what i'm talking
about i'm saying you know actually you
know even tabi's of which we've had
several
yeah i think
uh white and orange and and black just
just just those three colors
um
seem to
seem to correlate with some particular
uh types of personalities so i'll just
leave it at that for the moment
i wouldn't say what i think they are
point out later that there's you know
there's two ways that could happen it
could be that the coat color is
connected to something that actually
manifests as behavior or it could be
that the code color impacts the way the
world deals with them so black cats for
example to the extent that people have a
superstition black cats have a different
developmental experience of people this
is true although my experience and you
know but again this is anecdotal but
i've had
i guess i've had three black cats and
we've had we've had two
um my experience with black cats has
been that they are particularly
affectionate and loyal um which you
might expect the opposite given um
given
the superstitions around them i'm not so
sure about that i'm not so sure because
it may be that they
get less interaction
um and therefore are
they find someone who who doesn't treat
them like they're gonna cast a spell on
them or something yeah they treat them
well yep yep okay
okay
let's go to the questions that came in
on the darker submissions.com site
the claim that the vaccines can reduce
t-cell immunity is becoming increasingly
common among those critical of the
vaccines
i have not yet so i have not heard that
you heard that
no and i'm we're not done with the
question yet yeah i'm a little i want to
know more of what it
t cell immunity in
in people who have had covalent let's
see if the rest of the question gets
there
um
so let's just start again the claim that
the vaccines can reduce t cell immunity
is becoming increasingly common among
those critical of the vaccines i have
not yet seen any papers suggesting this
with the exception of a preprint saying
the second dose could do so in coveted
recovered individuals
when the paper was published that
reference was removed from the abstract
what is your current understanding of
the effect of the vaccines on t-cell
immunity and then there's a
link to
something that might be that pre-print
i've actually never heard this this is
this is news to me so
um
well i don't want to do too much
guessing because the current environment
is not hospitable
to even responsible
uh
navigation of hypotheticals but i will
say
you have an obvious interaction of a
small number of components right you
have antigen that antigen can be the
result of infection it can be the result
of vaccination
you have cells that respond to it of
multiple different classes to the extent
that a cell responds to an antigen of
one type or another means that the
pressure for another cell to respond to
it can be decreased because the antigen
is suddenly now covered in antibodies
for example
so there's lots of mechanisms for these
things to interact and one of the things
that i think
has been the most frustrating and
obnoxious is that there is no tolerance
for anybody who wants to try to figure
out what the various connections might
be all of that is considered
sacrilege
in an environment where the conclusion
is
overly simple and handed down from on
high and supposed to dictate
the rational behavior it's the opposite
of science it's what we're being forced
to engage with and then we're we're
they're being told that we know we must
god i can't speak we must pretend that
it is science like this is the highest
and best thing that humans do
and it is in fact um almost the opposite
okay so i was finally able to it's very
hard to click on uh links that people
send in this in this framework that
we've got here but
um okay so this is just the
the paper to which the question asker
was referring
but i think we that we did it as well as
we can given we don't know much about
this
hypothesis
wow this got really small there we go
hypothesis merck pissed the fda and cdc
off with the malnupira of your
announcement
the narrative has been vax only no early
treatment
merck did quote science by press release
fluvoxamine studies sat unpublished
since august it's now published to
fanfare shows effectiveness it undercuts
mark's drug both in profits and maybe
even getting an eua
i'm not i don't know enough about the
history to know what part of that is the
hypothesis or if the whole thing is the
hypothesis
well i think it's a
there's some observations in there and
the hype i don't know i don't know what
part of that is known
so
we don't know that mark pissed off
right anyone so that sounds that begins
this so
i don't know if the rest of it is all um
speculation as well or if some of these
are
observations that are there's some
observations in there
um the flavoxavine flavoxamine thing is
very interesting because this is a
early treatment repurposed drug
that appears to be
highly effective
it is
under utilized so we've got a tool that
we don't appear to be using it's
interesting that it has escaped the
usual mechanism for killing these things
off
right in other words
we now have evidence that it is
uh powerfully useful
and yet it does not seem to be radically
altering my understanding is it does not
seem to be radically altering our
approach to covid which is conspicuous
why wouldn't you use a tool that you
have now
i would say
it's
a more troubling tool because as an ssri
it's impacting
systems that matter and it may be a
comparatively better one but the point
is you really want to use the least
dangerous most effective drugs you have
at your disposal and this isn't the
least dangerous most effective drug that
we have at our disposal certainly of all
the repurposed drugs that um that i can
think of and i guess at the moment that
list is only three long but um
fluvoxamine ivermectin
hydroxychloroquine fluvoxamine is the
one that gives me by far the most pause
like i don't i i would not
if i came down with the case of covid
that wasn't sending me to the hospital i
would not want to be on fluoxamine
um
i am very concerned about ssris right
i'm very concerned about them too uh i
would certainly if you didn't have
access to the better drugs i would
certainly
uh use it rather than allow cova to run
its course
um
but
it depends on how bad i mean as always
there's actually a trade-off you know
and then saying that there's a trade-off
it's not saying i think of it is
fictional or you know i don't believe
that it can ever cause death for god's
sake people you know grow up but i am
concerned enough about ssris i've you
know i've i've read enough about the the
damage that they do and their
addictiveness
right such that uh i am i would i would
steer clear of that i would very
strongly steer clear of that uh unless
there was uh considerable strong urgent
reason to be on it right but i mean at
some level we are always
in this dumb spot which is we have had a
we humanity have had a crash course in
how to deal
with covid clinically and it includes
not just the drugs you mentioned
includes budesonide it includes
melatonin interestingly enough
um
and so the real question and you know
remember what podesinite is
nasal it's a oh yeah actually maybe a
question here nasal i think it may even
be over the counter
um oh so is melatonin so is melatonin
and so anyway the the real question is
what is the ideal use of this set of
useful tools and we can't have that
conversation right it's amazing that we
cannot um i also am just personally
curious whether or not melatonin
actually has an impact on
kovit itself or is it you know is it a
proxy for sleep because
or is it like vitamin d where it's the
deficiency you know if if your sleep is
so disturbed that somehow your melatonin
levels are off and i don't know i don't
exactly
know what that relationship is
um
you know is is basically having a sleep
deficit going to uh you know worsen your
covet outcome almost certainly yeah we
know we know that there's lots of
healing i mean there's a reason that
it's you know fluids and rest that
you're prescribed when you've got a
virus we don't have any useful tools for
which is that those two things actually
do work
right and they so and the dosages of
melatonin i must say are frighteningly
high i mean it's not a particularly
dangerous i mean four coveted four
covert yeah i mean they're they're also
really high just in the over the count
of the four the over the counter form
right you know at this point what we
have in our medicine cabinet for
occasional use is 300 micrograms and
very often it's at least an order of
magnitude more that you buy in pill form
hey zach
you want to let uh old yowley in
oh he's just yelling okay
okay
he recognized his affectionate nickname
um sorry anything else nope okay
vitamin k2 perfectly complements vitamin
d3 by reducing or eliminating the toxic
effects which are osteoporosis hardening
of the arteries and kidney stones to
name only a few
could you do a segment on the tremendous
effects of vitamin k2
i don't know very much yeah i don't but
i i think it's interesting i've also
heard that we
should look into the interaction with
magnesium
so anyway as we are pulled farther in
this direction i think it is it is worth
exploring the
um yeah i mean the problem is of course
that there's a billion
places that you can
uh that you can go um
i'm just trying to figure out i don't
even know
yeah activator x
k2 yeah it's it's some relatively newly
discovered in the 20th century
drug but i or
molecule
about which i know very little
in
the 100th q a you mentioned frustration
over how biology is represented in
science fiction highly recommend the
expanse
by james s a corey alien biology is
represented oh my god
is represented as hostile and
incompatible to earthly biology
interesting
i will
look into it
if selection favors youth over longevity
does this minimize the evolutionary
healing lens for medical conditions and
injuries of aging and their treatments
i don't 100 understand the question but
yes
in fact aging is the consequence of the
fact right or not aging but senescence
with age
is the consequence of the fact that
selection
sees late life
less well and therefore cares about it
less which has many interesting
consequences basically
the worse the senescence problem gets
the less likely
any particular feature is to be
cured because curing it does less if you
have
you know a hundred year old person has
in all likelihood numerous pathologies
and very little chance
of meaningfully affecting their fitness
at that point and so the selective
pressure even if there was an available
cure for some condition the pressure to
find it is very low
so what that what effect that has on
our
intentional study of these things is
debatable
you know in some sense the market is
driving what we seek and so what people
fear and are afflicted with is probably
the driving force
um yeah
it's pretty good
okay
this is a
high dollar value question but i don't
know enough about any of this stuff i'm
going to read it but i don't think i
have any opinion at all
um
the the biological background is
not vast diagnosed with crohn's
and
as
spondylitis
i don't remember what as is with mild
psoriatic art md wants to offer twice
monthly hemire injection which shall
always immune response dilemma is
effects or not to facts uh for what
injection uh humira i don't know
i just don't know enough about any of
those conditions to to be able to say
yeah sorry sorry
um
any thoughts about using air purifiers
to reduce the risk of catching covenant
doors
i just bought one that filters down to
0.1 micron finer than n95 masks with uvc
love you both
um yeah you know this this uh filter
that we be that
we have as a sponsor as of this week
doesn't filter to quite that i don't
remember what it is i think it might be
0.3 microns but um and it didn't test
for covet but in third-party tests it
was looking at viruses small viruses and
was filtering out viruses so um you know
the the capacity and you know and some
such filters are used in medical
settings as well
but uh it's not you know opening the
windows
uh regularly is
is
still definitely advised
yeah
my guess is
the filtering is a little bit of a red
herring
viruses are very very tiny filtering
them out is not a straightforward matter
because you may not be filtering the
particle you may be filtering a droplet
right or an aerosol yep
um
they are
so i think often it's the uvc
technology that is being um promoted as
as
so the question is how well is this
designed so in other words how much time
does a if a virus gets past the
physical filtering how much time is it
exposed to the uvc
is that sufficient to break down
something functional about it right
those are all good questions maybe that
works let's suppose you designed one
that was cruddy right in which things
passed through very quickly and it
didn't manage to catch them but
because it moved a lot of air
a it
evaporated the
particles the droplets and the aerosols
more quickly than a static room right so
just simply moving the same volume of
air would cause those things the virus
to be
freed of its uh water molecules
uh potentially would that have an impact
um
it will
disperse the air so to the extent that
there might be a coveted source in some
place and that means there's some pocket
of the room that is disproportionately
highly concentrated right so make more
uniform the distribution right and so
the point is okay let's say all of these
things are in play and none of them are
you know more than 15 percent effective
but the combined effect might be
substantial
you know
so does having the thing in the room
working have some effect yeah yeah
probably it does yep
i agree i agree with all that
uh
submitting the stats for romania so this
is just like
here's some true things or here's some
things that are said that are supposedly
true
on october 28th and 2021
in
romania
there are 22
130 coveted positives in the hospital
this seems like an incredibly high
number but we aren't given the
population of romania 459 of them are
kids
which is a
very small percentage and it's actually
not as tiny as it might be for it's
about
three percent to three percent
vaccinated population is 32.48
yeah that's not enough statistics to
make any sense of them yeah right um
because we don't know and we also don't
have the definition of vaccinated
yeah although like i said in the first
hour the first hour and a half um i've
yet to see
i've
i have yet to see any definition that
sets an end point
or has a beginning point that is
anything except for
two weeks
after the final shot of the series if
it's a one or a two shot series right
and this is inherently garbage because
of course of course you could define the
steps you could define as many
categories as you want right you can
define
no vaccine you can define
uh one vaccine
with uh the number of
weeks after you can define two vaccines
number of weeks after and then you can
combine any two categories for any
calculation you want to do so failing to
deliver
parsable numbers
of of course i mean this is
a point i've made before is
oh my god this is biology there really
aren't that many binaries there's one at
least and that's the one that like the
woke left is taking issue with sex you
know male and female and then it creates
these insane fictional binaries like
vaccinated versus not vaccinated where
it's not a binary so it's you know
ginning up binaries that don't exist and
rejecting a binary that does and it's
all incoherent i mean i disagree with
you a little bit on there aren't that
many binaries i think there are lots of
binaries
um
but
what are some others i mean you know all
of
phylogeny almost uh those are
dichotomies
okay i mean i don't see the distinction
um you know autotroph heterotroph is
good so
in any case plenty of plenty of binaries
that we can point to but the problem is
with this claimed binary
there's an obvious definition
right if you want to do the vaccinated
versus unvaccinated then did you get a
vaccine or didn't you that's the binary
and the problem is by using a definition
that seems to be no i mean i don't i
don't i don't think that that's a fair
definition either it's not useful but
the idea
the idea that we have to accept a
definition that is um that is misleading
and that we're never allowed to talk
about or that note that no one who is is
mostly talking about what unvaccinated
means
um is talking about in the mainstream
media is
misleading at best well i i don't
disagree about that but my point is when
you say
unvaccinated and you are in the middle
of claiming things like pandemic of the
unvaccinated
right you call to mind people who have
not complied
and when many of the people in your
category have complied and have come
down with
the illness anyway because your vaccine
isn't very good at preventing it or it
in fact makes it more likely for a short
period of time you create exactly the
reverse impression
and so i i don't think that's an
accident in the slightest and it's not
an ambiguity either it's a
it's a use of a term that seems to
suggest one thing but very frequently
suggests something different
yep
if you had never heard of ivermectin
against covid how would that have
changed your perception of the vaccines
congratulations on the book
well we were
i don't remember exactly the first time
we ran to ivermectin
during the pandemic but we were talking
about our concern about the impending
vaccines
long before we were ever talking
publicly about hypermectin
i think
the sense
that
there was a clear
off-label
a clear drug that could be used
off-label that could be very useful in
early treatment and prophylaxis
um
made
it
easier
to
not be really really deeply concerned
about the safety signal that's in these
vaccines
it made that it made some decisions
there easier yeah once you have this on
the table but but the facts are what the
facts are like right but i i think i can
answer the question that's being asked
okay right so
you want to you want to rephrase or say
what you think is being asked absent
early treatment what would you think
about the vaccines
and the answer is we were initially
very alarmed about what was being
claimed about their safety because it
couldn't possibly be right yeah doesn't
mean back even before the rollout like
last november december the point is
to say that something is safe is to say
that you know it doesn't do harm it's
not to say
um
that
it won't you know that it won't turn out
to do
harm but the point is to say you know it
means that you know what the long-term
implications are and they couldn't
possibly have known so there was an
initial lie
about the security of these things we
got into trouble for an analogy that i
think is still perfectly accurate right
how do you know what safe means
right it is not synonymous with harm if
you pick up a gun and put it to your
head and pull the trigger and it goes
click and you put the gun down was that
safe
everybody knows that wasn't safe was it
harmful it's not obviously harmful right
you got away with it and so the point is
to say that these things were safe was
to imply that they knew no harm can come
and they obviously didn't we have now
discovered harms that did come from it
and
we uh also cannot know what the
long-term implications are right and so
the point is we were alarmed and i guess
the point if you didn't have
a cabinet
uh a theoretical cabinet of drugs that
work against this and turn it into a
manageable disease right that doesn't
make these vaccines any better than they
are exactly it doesn't make them more
effective it doesn't make them safe and
the point is then the question is how
good can you get at the game of avoiding
the disease yeah right how much better
can we get at figuring out what
behaviors actually prevent disease
transmission and how to deploy them and
i think you know if if only we would
avail ourselves of the tools that we
have at our disposal that's not such an
important question anymore because we do
have those tools but in the absence of
them that would be the question so
um
there's another question here that is
relevant please can you list all the
detailed precautions you are currently
taking against covid
um and i don't think we're going to say
all of the ways that our you know our
behavior has been mitigated by this
pandemic but
um specifically in terms of
you know
we are and i specifically am not a fan
of supplements i
don't i don't like taking pills pills
for health um
it doesn't doesn't make
a lot of evolutionary sense to me but at
the moment
uh we are we are taking d and i have no
qualms with that but we're also taking c
and zinc and quercetin
sometimes turmeric
uh and
and
you're continuing to prophylax with
ivermectin as is as is zach
yep um
i you know
the recommendation has come to increase
the amount of ivermectin uh in light of
the increased uh infectiousness of
delta and it's not obvious that that
makes sense to do in light of the fact
that this is a novel use of ivermectin
but you know we do lots of other things
too we still we do
dine out
we dine out
outdoors
um
we
use
masks
whenever it is
required
i will say
yeah i mean it's it's just required a
lot here but increasingly it's not
it's not clear to either of us that that
is
anything more than theater yeah i don't
i don't believe it um but
we do take that precaution
um
but you know look i mean we've we've
always
been careful i mean this really you in
particular have driven us to be very
very careful since long before covid
to not expose others if we ever thought
we were sick yep uh and um you know it
it comes with social costs i mean not so
much during covet like maybe this is one
of the lasting what's one of the few
lasting impacts of this damn thing that
will be positive
that if we if we emerge from this to any
sense of normalcy and people can deal
with the cognitive dissonance that they
have trapped themselves in by believing
completely mutually um
incompatible things
uh
from here on out
you don't get penalized
for calling in sick
when you feel sick or for not going to
school when you feel sick
there and yes that disrupts systems and
yes it makes it harder on the teachers
and the employers and that is all true
and certainly we've been in that
position both as faculty who didn't want
to have to miss a day of class because
what was that going to do to the
schedule and dealing with students who
missed and then how do you allow them to
how do you how do you even make up when
what you did was spend five hours
talking with the students right like how
do you make that up but the fact is that
it shouldn't be
anyone's um right and certainly not
obligation to go into a room full of
people with a respiratory illness and
risk making them all sick so you know
that's that's one that's just that's one
thing and
um
and
basically being cognizant of
um
distancing
from
people when it is when it is possible
and not putting ourselves into positions
uh where uh
toriyama beginning people say well
unfortunately though or maybe it's
fortunately
in order for this
in order for the right lesson to come
out of the pandemic let's say that we
somehow get our act together we get
ourselves out of the pandemic and then
there's a question about what lessons to
retain from it
you need a more
pro-social society in order to even
deploy that
piece of hard-won wisdom
right because what you don't want is a
system in which
because we now all understand what we
should have understood all along which
is that it is bad to have people coming
into work who are sick that the cost
even in terms of the amount of work that
gets done
is substantial because of all of the
other people that they will get sick
what's more it's extremely
uh indecent to get people sick when you
know you have something transmissible or
suspected
but the problem is how do you get to the
place where you really do call in sick
when you really are
sick with something transmissible and
you really don't when you aren't is you
need a system in which we are kinder and
decenter to each other and in which your
uh
employment does a better job of taking
care of you and that this isn't all so
goddamn transactional yes and so the
question is we're a long way from
a society in which we're not basically
dealing with each other in transactional
terms all the time yeah and that auto
that ought to be a focus yep indeed
okay different sort of question john and
actually zach i forgot to notice when we
started i mean i did actually and i
forgot
really
yeah okay
john mcwhorter's new book woke racism is
great and contains helpful thoughts on
how to interact or not with the elect as
he calls them
uh so i saw that question i was like i
know i read it
months ago and i went to the site zach
you can show
this is this is a great book um and i
read it um because
he asked me to blurb it and i thought
well maybe it's not on there but it is
so here's what i had to say about it all
right i found it on the amazon site um
mcwhorter brings us much-needed pointed
social commentary with humor and grace
give this book to those who are
questioning the new religion even those
who have found it woke racism has the
capacity to melt the hatred and fervor
that is now all the rage and to bring
love and forgiveness logic and discourse
back into fashion that's really a great
book
i have noticed but it does not surprise
me we only have or i guess i would send
an electronic form we only have the
early early version so we should get a
copy and um and talk about it on air so
yes highly recommend woke racism by john
mccorder
the book that unfortunately um only a
black man could write um but but he did
it
would you expect the human species to
split evolutionarily along racial lines
if not how do you imagine the next fork
in our road
not a long race um yeah i mean in fact
the funny thing about race is it is the
evidence of us not splitting along these
lines um you know it does not mean that
people don't affiliate that way
traditionally but the point is um
human beings have remained a species
even though in many ways different
lineages have behaved in ways that in
other creatures we would call different
species ecologically distinct creatures
but less and less the the more into the
future we are going the less and less
that is the case oh yeah yeah right we
are
we are now global we are now global and
i mean you know this goes back to the
conversation we were having uh in the
initial podcast but there's something
totally fascinating about the fact that
you have people whose
skin color is so out of step with their
latitude right right that is evidence in
both directions right in both directions
and it causes melanoma in you know
fair-skinned people who encounter too
much sun as they go towards the equator
and it causes vitamin d deficiency in
dark-skinned people as they move towards
the poles and the point is i just want
to point out that apparently
in people who have melanoma greater sun
exposure is associated with a lower risk
of mortality
yeah so that's that's some research that
i cited in that vitamin d deficiency
article that we were talking about so um
melanoma itself is should not be taken
as the the bugaboo that we all have in
our head well
melanoma is very dangerous apparently
greater sun exposure and probably
greater vitamin d is somewhat protective
in people who have melanoma melanoma is
much more likely if you have
low melanin content
yes um
so anyway it's a very complex
interesting puzzle but at some level
right
we are living in a world in which
people's
i mean it's almost the proof of hyper
novelty yeah
the fact that people's skin tone has not
caught up to their new latitude
is the perfect example of hey your
evolution is not fast enough to deal
with the rate of change and is that bad
no it's great but the point is it takes
diligence to figure out okay what do you
do about this suppose you are a
dark-skinned person living
at low latitudes or high latitudes um
what is the right response and you know
these are solvable problems but they're
not solvable problems if we're not
allowed to talk about them right yeah so
apparently i won't be able to pull up
the research but um
scandinavia so throughout europe vitamin
d deficiency is widespread just as it is
in north america with the exception of
the far north where you would expect if
this was a cline you know away from away
from the equator uh vitamin d deficiency
to be highest the farthest away you are
but basically you've got a um you know a
culinary history of high fish intake and
also
a lot of supplementation in the food
itself so
and in fact one of the diabetes studies
that i looked at was
supplementing with the
in infants and i think it was norway
that then produces much lower rates of
diabetes one i think it was later on
so there's just there's all sorts of
vitamin d supplementation in the
scandinavian countries the exception
to the finding that scandinavia has much
lower rates of
vitamin d deficiency and also has lower
rates of covid
is in the sub-populations
of
new immigrants and most of the new
immigrants in scandinavia are
dark-skinned
they're coming from north africa and the
middle east and
you know probably they aren't adopting
the um the cuisine as much and maybe not
eating as many of the foods that are
supplemented on this i'm i'm out on a
limb i'm not sure about this but the
fact that you have dark-skinned people
moving to far northern climbs climb
climbs in that case
and um
immediately developing a vitamin d
deficiency and also being more
susceptible to covet while that all fits
doesn't it yeah it fits uh perfectly and
actually it mirrors
this sort of distinction that we saw was
gonna seem far afield but during the
boxing day tsunami
you had people who had been living on
these coasts
uh
um the in the end
they
lost not a single person to the tsunami
because they had mythology that told
them exactly what to do even though the
periodicity of these things
meant that no living person had seen
anything like it you know
nor had any of their ancestors that they
had met yes whereas in the was it the
city of banda aceh on the west coast the
very western tip of
java i think which had a mixture of
people who had lived there for a long
time and presumably a lot of people who
whose ancestors hadn't there was um
incredibly high death rates incredibly
high density and also the west coast of
thailand which also i love tourists
right and so the point is there was a
big difference it didn't matter that you
were a coastal person and that you might
have been there for a couple generations
right you need to be there a lot longer
in order to have adapted and in this
case adapted means to have the correct
mythology to know what the hell to do
right yeah right
is modern housing junk shelter
are there any resources or tips for
designing new ones
where you could still just barely invite
others over
oh i read that a few times and i
couldn't make sense of it i think i
think what it's asking is could you
design
a really you know a shelter that is not
junk shelter but that would still
satisfy enough sort of the social
expectations that you could have people
over and they wouldn't run screaming
oh yeah in fact i think uh they might
dig it yeah i do too
yeah there's a lot i mean you know
there's there's various things you see
um you know
housing
i think i actually
before you go on i i think also this is
now a reference to our repeated
references to things like junk sex junk
media junk food right so junk food being
the only one of those that's out there
in the world um but yeah junk shelter
hey housing well i would just say you
know there's a way once you know what
the consumer wants right they want more
space they want a vaulted ceiling in
their entryway they want do they yeah
right the point is oh we can do that you
know what they want is they want hollow
core doors
so we've now
shopped for houses a couple of times
together um i mean a lot of times but
for
a couple of moments in our relationship
when we actually ended up buying a house
and without ever talking to one another
you know starting i guess it would have
been in like 2002 when we were shopping
for a house in olympia
um
both of us were going around like
knocking on the doors and sort of like
yeah grabbing onto the door frame
such garbage and actually the house
ended up buying in olympia which was in
many ways wonderful and in some ways it
just really needed better climate
control it was very leaky
um but it was on a it was on a plot of
land it was on six acres that was
plotted for four houses and one of them
was empty when we bought it
and uh
and so the three houses that were there
had all been built in the 70s and then
this one house was built in the first
year or two of us living there and
um we would
we would go over many nights and check
out what they were doing um and just and
you know and and see what construction
looked like and you know watch it and
figure predict what we thought the
layout was going to be but also the more
and more built it got the crappier and
crappier it revealed itself to be yes
you know at this you know 1970s houses
which had problems we the house we
bought was just on the cusp of um
getting rid of the asbestos for instance
right and lead in paint now maybe lead
in paint was no yeah
our house was too new to have the lead
and paint yeah yeah um but uh but the
newer stuff was it's yeah total junk
housing well my shelter my sense is
there's a difference between
um an item that's actually built to last
indefinitely and an item yeah that is
built
with a short time horizon until it ends
up in the landfill and the materials
on some of these new houses
are short lived materials and it's
there's no excuse for building a house
with this of course the price of the
house to buy it to get in is cheaper
yeah was it punk board oh
it turns out
that was actually an attempt yes a punk
board was this substitute for the
plywood sheeting on
the house that we ended up buying and
the idea was sold as a solution to an
insulation problem
um because it had a better r value than
which is just a measure of insulation
but you know
god damn it you want plywood sheeting on
your house for multiple reasons both
first
you could practically dig your way out
through it yeah yes gross stuff
completely terrible um but yeah we we
we should do we should just
riff on architecture and building at
some point but maybe we did just a
little bit we did just a little bit just
a little bit
um
have you seen the compilation videos of
sponsored by pfizer ads on news outlets
oh yeah i have not it's unbelievable
what's the what's this here's basically
what happened to black bottom line what
upshot bottom line what's the bottom
shot what's the up line
um
so the compilation
involves
pfizer
having predictably
sponsored
all of these ostensibly
news
distributing
shows and of course the news should go
wrong
what could possibly go wrong right so
then you know the basic game is well
they're not hiding that they sponsored
it and you're not accusing these
journalistic shows of
bowing to the economic desires of they
need to eat
they
what you don't want them to eat
what kind of monster are you in any case
it's just nonsense and of course it's
even more nonsensical because
so much of you know what is pfizer all
right pfizer is a
it's a for-profit corporation i thought
it was going to be a philosophical
question
um no i mean it just
the
partial participation
in a normal
um
series of market forces
is a little bit jaw-dropping right i
mean in other words how much are these
vaccines well they're free
really
do tell uh yeah they're yes not free is
not how i would describe them um so
anyway uh free and safe
they are they are free and safe yeah
but yes we've seen them in their
horrifying relationships yeah i have not
i believe that they're horrifying but i
have not seen them
um
what are the rules for us who are
medically exempt i feel like i'm now a
leper amongst family and friends through
no fault of my own
well there's nothing wrong with leopards
i mean it's a beautiful cat a dangerous
but you know at a distance is that not
what he said no no
i think it was a she but i i've already
clicked yes so i can't go back and check
all right
there are no rules unfortunately yeah i
don't know that there are any rules
because uh i i think none of us really
know
where
we are
um i would say the rules for how careful
you need to be to protect others
be very very careful that's for real on
the other hand
you're obviously being lied to and
you're being lied to
uh
at peril to your health and even worse
your children's health and
um
that changes you know basically the
thing that wants to shame you and
mandate you and
exempt you
um
if it has to that thing is in breach of
contract
it just is yep sure is
uh so
this is a link that i have not gone to
yet but it says love you both your
explanation of capture leaves out uh fcc
and wireless there's a lot of corruption
there and there's a
there's a link here
i don't know anything about this i mean
i have no i have no
yeah i mean look i i'm concerned about
every
choke point and obviously communication
involves choke points and you know
wireless is one and
uh other things regulated by the fcc
would be others
you're probably referring to something
specific that we don't know about but
it's a major concern yeah
okay here's a totally different question
i finished the audiobook nice
uh
question mating dating strategy for a 40
year old male looking for the one woman
who wants a family with me not just to
be a step dad
dating apps suck red flags question mark
that's a big question um where did we
just have this discussion on a
one podcast or another we were talking
about the difference between and i've
now seen this mirrored in some other
realm was it the npr we did a we did we
had such a great conversation um on this
npr show yeah which i don't think is out
yet and i don't even know if it'll be
available to anyone who's not in the
sort of virginia dc area which is um
where
uh where was it was it with him
yeah it may be yeah um i think
the
no it may not have been actually in any
that's also possible
the point was
how do you make yourself
um
desirable to
a potential mate and the answer is
really what should be desirable in a
potential mate is not that they've made
themselves desirable but that they have
done
other things right it should be not the
objective of the exercise but a uh
a byproduct of the exercise and so i
guess i would say
you know you're looking for somebody who
is interested in
um teaming up with you and having a
family but to the extent that that's
what they're interested in that is kind
of a red flag yep um
they should be interested in that as a
as a uh
in addition to whatever they're actually
interested in yeah in life yeah i guess
um at the moment and maybe this is just
i don't think this bias will fade i
don't think this is a bias of the moment
but um
any indicators of
personality traits over in that cluster
b
diagnosis uh space
are red flags and so you know what i
mean this is like a dsm
uh psychological term and i've been i've
been thinking about i'll explain it in a
minute but i mentioned
my sub stack a couple weeks ago
and the one just for subscribers uh that
i've been listening to the disaffected
pod uh with host joshua slocum and it's
i said in there that it was an acquired
taste and i have now acquired it
it's really very good and you know his
his take is his bent his his sort of
framing hypothesis if you will
is that cluster b traits are actually um
present in so much of the deranging
behavior that we are seeing culture wide
and they're being celebrated rather than
tamped down and corrected which is what
a normal societal response should be so
the four cluster b diagnoses are
narcissism
although the narcissism small n is
present in all of these narcissism
um
sociopathy or asocial personality
disorder uh histrionic personality
disorder and borderline
and uh you can look up any of those or
just cluster b and or you know really
just you know you you want the easy way
and go listen to
uh joshua slocum on the disaffected pod
and he'll give you an earful about them
yep you might consider avoiding cluster
b or you'll be cluster b [ __ ]
yeah
i mean you
you will come to realize if you haven't
already that you have interacted with
some such people in your life
um and the one of the things that i
one of the ways that i began to frame
this many years ago at the point that i
had an interac a set of interactions
that was um
crazy making like quite literally crazy
making uh was
i was sort of looking around my world
going like why is everything suddenly
off kilter and nothing is making sense
and at the point that i identified the
human being who was present in all of
the mystifying crazy making interactions
including sometimes you know two degrees
deep but when i could go to someone else
and say wait was that person actually
the source of that information that is
patently false
it was always that one person and so
very often you can find if you know if
you're feeling off guilt or if you're
feeling like my social landscape is no
longer making sense um
all too often it can be that there is a
source and that often they will have one
of these cluster b diagnoses so red
flags
those are some
i didn't say any of them except to name
the diagnoses yep
now the harder problem is that because
these things are now being um
they are now spreading presumably lots
of people who don't have a pathology per
se are nonetheless
exact and this is actually his point in
this that you know you don't there are a
lot of people who are behaving because
they're encouraged to behave this way
right so and they like they actually
have no excuse except that they're
getting social cred right they're
getting they're getting points for
behaving like narcissists like
sociopaths like histrionics even like
borderlines which is the scariest one so
i would say one um thing that you can
use as a proxy for the absence of this
is whether the person is
tolerant of
folks of different viewpoints in other
words
it's all well and good to be
uh a liberal even a democrat
if you're a liberal or a democrat
who can't tolerate
you know discussions with
conservatives or republicans
there's something wrong with you yeah
that's that's a red flag sure yeah like
whatever the person who you might be
interested in
his ideology is beliefs if they also
proudly wave the and i won't talk to the
other side then they run away i won't
talk to the other side and neither
should you and the point is that look i
don't know of a side that's got this so
wired that you can afford to just forego
the wisdom outside of it yeah totally
okay um
hold on this
[Music]
sorry
okay
um how can an employer with high
liability trust their employees
professional judgment
how can a professional
work ethically when the prescription
supersedes the evaluation
thanks i think there's a lot
in here that is in code and i'm not
quite sure that i have decoded it i
think i got the first part okay maybe
um i'll just read it again how can an
employer with high liability trust their
employees professional judgment
so if you are an employer
and you have
risk
right if you are employing people to
utilize
dangerous machinery
you know in public
how can you trust
your employees to do it in such a way
that you don't end up uh
with a massive loss you know somebody
having been injured because somebody
worked for you was behaving
casually and
um
i mean a it strikes me that this is sort
of the legitimate reason for things like
osha
that basically there are rules
that yes they're cumbersome and annoying
but they're there so that
a person who operates according to them
you know the risk of them doing
something terrible is much reduced
but i don't know i mean this is a
serious and frightening question and i
must tell you i've been increasingly
having conversations with people
who run businesses
and
they are seeing
they are having incredible difficulty
finding
help that is capable of doing the job
that is basically
willing that does have judgment and
discernment that has people who have
judgment to deploy it in the service of
a job either people take a job and they
become an automaton that doesn't have
any judgment
well i mean this is this is an obvious
downstream effect of not providing
children risk and adventure and actual
problems to solve that actually need to
be solved for about which there are
stakes right right like and you know so
they they've never been able to do that
before but they've been schooled and
then they show up at an employer and
suddenly you're supposed to just turn
that on that's that's not that's not how
we work right now i also think that
there is a longer term
problem
we are finding out something our system
has shaken loose some stuff with covid
where lots of people have left work and
aren't going back and some of this is
organic and normal in light of the fact
that a they've figured out how to
survive
absent
the paycheck
right they're cobbling together a life
some other way they've found slack in
the system somewhere else
and basically we've got a
we've got a kind of a top-down predatory
system
and the top-down kind of
yeah kinda um but that top-down
predatory system has caused
everybody to basically feel short
changed and to maybe actually even be
shortchanged by the people up the chain
from them
and this means that at some level
i think the people at the layer that i'm
talking to that's now frightening to
hear from right people who are running
businesses and can't find competent
staff and so they're now doing jobs that
are way below their pay grade because
they can't they can't trust anybody that
they would hire to do those jobs
even highly credentialed people
right yeah but
that's part of what we're hearing
people who have
who have who who did the right stuff and
who got credentials from the important
places are showing up unable to do
things that right they take the boxes
but they don't have the skills
but
you would expect
the wage mechanism to take care of this
in other words you would expect
wages to rise
and that to cause people who wouldn't
take a certain job to consider taking
that job because it now pays well enough
to justify them bringing their skills to
the table the problem is if those wages
that are required to get the competent
people to take those jobs are too high
for the business in question to pay
those wages
right and then the question is well
i mean it's also there's also the
question of how you
the wage mechanism sound there's there's
a magical part to me in that story which
is um all you have to do is raise the
offer and all the people out there with
the skills will find you
and it seems to me that some number of
the people who actually have the skills
uh don't know to look
or actually may not even be aware that
what they do is so unique you know one
of those quotes that i read from one of
those nobel laureates who was saying um
yeah most of the you know used to be the
people who went into advanced physics
had worked you know as a plumber's
apprentice or an electrician's
apprentice or something before and i
worked i took apart radios and such
uh this is
the those two those two worlds
since since we've been growing up and
like both you and i played in those
worlds but um this is it has been
understood that white collar and blue
collar are somehow distinct and this
this is part of the problem like you
know the the idea that if you have these
physical skills around um
rather skills around understanding the
physical universe in which you find
yourself that that could and and might
translate into having some
more abstract skill abstract skills is
well understood by some nobel laureates
but not well understood by a lot of the
people who actually don't have skills
but have credentials right
but even worse is
all right the wage mechanism will
ultimately solve this the problem is the
wage mechanism will solve this it may be
that there aren't enough people who have
these skills and so yes they will
ultimately get paid
but the point is you know
you know whoever you are running
whatever business it is that needs some
skilled people
the the
supply and demand of people with that
skills
the low supply means that you may have
to jack the wage up really really high
to attract them away from whatever
they're doing so ultimately that will
correct because people will see very
high wages for people with this sort of
skill set but the point is how many
generations is it going to take for
people to get the training whatever that
training looks like whether it's self
training whether it's academic training
but
here's the crazy part
at the same point we are seeing
not enough people with the skills
necessary to do the skilled work that
needs to be done
what's happening to the skill generating
part of civilization
right it's gone insane and it's now
telling people that male and female are
some choice you can right that i mean
this is my point about the credentials
being misleading well not only the
credentials misleading but we now have
that quadrant of the economy that is
dedicated to making people smarter
actively making them dumber right and so
the point is as you
increase the amount you'll pay for
anybody who can still think and then
you've got saboteurs in the colleges and
universities
punishing people for thinking
what is
where does this come out and we can't
possibly afford generations to sort this
out we're too vulnerable right right
this can't go on yep
we need a new system
we need a new system
15 years ago yes we do
all right um but uh
but right now we're gonna go off air we
are and maybe part of what we'll be
doing is talking about a new system but
not
in front of all y'alls uh so we'll be
back next week but not with the q a
we'll be we will come to you with our
regular uh regularly scheduled podcast a
bit later than normal we don't yet know
exactly how much later
but on saturday for episode 103 that'll
be
uh november 6th i guess
we will
we will endeavor cannot promise we will
endeavor to show up with all the answers
so you won't even have any questions no
we won't no that's that's wrong no we
won't i won't
[Music]
again i just try it out this is this is
what i live with this
it is and it could be worse
admiration it could be
so incredible
yeah it could be a lot more that's true
oh my god oh my goodness how could it be
worse i've been out what i comfort
myself
it's bad but wow could it be worse
all right guys
thank you for joining us
be good to the ones you love eat good
food and get outside be well everyone
[Music]
[Music]
you